[Musik]
was ist mit Cheater ja ich brauche noch
Apartment so kann ich das übers Handy
kaufen ah ja guck mal hier kann ich mir
Sachen kaufen verfügbare Immobilien
danach guck mal hier haben wir ein paar
wir haben 400.000 wir können uns hier in
Apartment gönnen sollen wir das machen
okay ich kaufe jetzt einfach mal ein
Apartment das heißt der Plan ist wie ich
kauf uns einen Apartment da können wir
zusammenleben immer der Partner oder
stellzenhausen
nehmen oder sehe ich auch aber einer
sagt nein äh ein Casino Apartment scheiß
drauf ich habe es jetzt schon gekauft
Handy wir haben ein Haus wie nein
Apartment ist geiler warum schreibt ihr
das nicht vorher ich habe gerade 95%
mein Geld ist ausgegeben
hinterher
Straße rechts runter wegen Auto ein paar
Sekunden später
oh mein Gott
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich zeig dir das jetzt mal okay weißt du
ich habe mir da auch so ein paar
Gedanken gemacht ich habe das jetzt
nicht ohne Grund gekauft alle wollten ja
hier im Chat dass ich eine Appartement
kaufe Idioten ja wir fahren jetzt
erstmal ganz entspannt zu meinem Haus
das ist 1,3 km Entfernung
man hat einen schönen Blick auf die City
das ist mir immer wichtig ne ich sag ja
immer lagellack
Lage Lage Lage
und natürlich auch die Nachbarschaft ist
wichtig guck mal wie schön dass sie
jetzt mit dem alten Baum bestand den
schönen hohen Bäumen guck mal hier was
sie für Autos fahren wundervoll und
nicht weit entfernt 300 Meter wohne ich
Sandy du siehst schon ne Palmen wie
sonst was Leute haben hier schöne putzen
und wenn wir jetzt hier vorne ankommen
siehst du auf der linken Seite mein neu
erworbenes Haus
das hier
hey das ist doch total hübsch das ist
wirklich total schön oder kann man hier
reingehen
kann was machen die in meinem Haus
er den Ruf an ich bin der neue Käufer
wie don't talk to me ihr steht vor
meinem Haus verpiss dich
nicht
mehr nein
[Musik]
das war da oh nee ja was mir wichtig war
war das nicht schöne Häuser in der
Nachbarschaft habe
mein Auto jetzt hier natürlich in meiner
Garage
schön Auto reinfahren ich komme nicht
rein alles gut
Sandy ich komme jetzt wieder raus mit
meinem Auto wo bist du
[Musik]
ein bisschen kaputt gefahren gerade das
Handy
Garage sehen
[Musik]
krass Einrichtung
dass man halt einen Helden Look hat guck
mal hier vorne läuft gerade Basketball
bisschen Fernsehen aber ich will zeigen
was
[Musik]
zeigen wo bleibt ihr als erstes hängen
halt die Flasche weg
[Musik]
also das hier ist die Küche bei der
Küche habe ich mir halt gedacht da
müssen wir sonst
[Musik]
muss los Bruder
die haben wir extra 8
Stühle habe ich mir besorgt von Vitra
und ein Glas damit man genau sieht was
äh alles so abgeht hier und Wasser unter
dem Tisch passiert hier vorne genau
weißt du schon siehst das ist meine
Bomben die rauchen mal ein bisschen
können uns auch sofort chillen ein
bisschen Fernsehen gucken und so
also ich komme gar nicht klar
wir stehen aus einem Kamin und im Regal
wo jetzt ein paar Bücher von mir drin
sind paar Preise die ich gewonnen habe
[Musik]
okay mache ich das denn hier auf
du kennst ja super bei dir zu Hause okay
dann fahren wir jetzt noch einmal fahren
wir jetzt noch einmal uns kurz
pisswasser holen also dieses Bier wie
das hier heißt wenn ich sage dir ab
jetzt ich brauche keinen Unfall auf den
drei Kilometer
[Musik]
wo bin ich jetzt eigentlich bin ich noch
drin
oder bin ich schon abgekratzt wir sind
beide noch drin alles gut
jedoch weiter Auto
geht noch weiter
hier können wir hier parken direkt boah
Sandy
wir kaufen uns Bier guck mal hier
pisswasser sogar im Angebot 6 Dollar
Sixpack kaufst du ins Wasser ich äh Bier
ich ich genieß den Ausblick boah jetzt
hier mit dem boah das ist geil
Alter schon
schön mit dem Malibu Hütten hier Laser
Kauf du mal ich kann es irgendwie nicht
kaufen
hallo
auch hier
und wie geht denn das Milch kaufen
oder muss ich auch mal ganz kurz gucken
was
sagt die das kostet mehr als ich im Jahr
verdiene und läuft weg
[Musik]
andere sitzen
unten rein wie die Assis die Kölner sind
da Sandra ich mache das was ich sonst
nie macht
[Musik]
ich brauche eine Kippe die schmeißt ja
auch hier hin ist mir egal und ich
trinke noch eine Dose Sprung und die
sind gut was auch immer das ist die kann
ich essen krass Alter wir haben eine
richtig geile Zeit geil einfach tauschen
hey wie kann man tauchen
[Musik]
ich will tauchen nicht Sandra
ich rasch komplett aus
ja aber doch gesehen ich wollte mich
noch hier ins Lagerfeuer setzen und
dadurch
sagen gut mein Fehler okay Leute das war
der GTA Stream wir hoffen es hat euch
gefallen wir haben auf jeden Fall noch
mal oder in ein zwei Wochen oder so
normal mit GTA live zu gehen aber dann
mit einem Plan dann nehmen wir uns das
vor dann äh kaufen
dann machen wir eine geile Party oder so
[Musik]